now she's going to take your energy away
and you won't be able to move her at all
now get in the same position grab her by
the waist and you will not be able to
move here yes
the ability to not be picked up this is
a perplexing video go for it in that
trip we went to meet the mastermind
behind this stunt in his secret
magician's lair my favorite thing about
being a magician I get to make people
ponder the impossible believe things
that may or may not be the truth and
also just entertain people and just have
fun
perfect yeah you're a big guy no big
deal I was a born prankster it's really
enjoyable to just watch people be
frustrated a little bit okay especially
a really big guy they're like come on
what is going on
so is rich some sort of pickup wizard or
is there a more rational explanation
what a fear should be magic is just
science in motion when the men pick her
up the first time she relaxes and she
allows her arms to fall naturally on the
men's shoulders or arms and she's also
quite close to them and this means that
they can use the power in their legs as
well as their arms to lift her up very
easily perfect yeah you're a big guy no
big deal so what changes on the second
attempt she leans back and tenses her
arms and this maintains the distance she
shifts her center of mass further away
from the guy by increasing this distance
she's effectively increased the amount
of force required to lift her up due to
something called door a torque is a
force that creates a rotation the torque
is given by the force which is the
weight of the woman multiplied by the
distance she is away from the pivot
which is the shoulder she creates a
greater torque and they have to use a
greater force to live
there's two parts to it there's my job
as the person who's gonna plan a
suggestion in someone's mind from this
moment on you will not be able to lift
her and then there's Nancy's job who
resists and adjusts the physics those
two things come together you have magic
yeah
also known as science yeah there you're
back you're back to full strength again
brother
you